so I don't want to overdo the polling
discussions we've only been talking
about polling like every couple of weeks
recently but there are some really
interesting things going on in the polls
that make me want to talk about it again
today Joe Biden has again had another
really bad week in polling he keeps
dropping and the beneficiary this week
of Biden dropping in the polls has been
Elizabeth Warren rather than some of the
other historical beneficiaries like for
example Bernie Sanders Elizabeth Warren
is climbing again and actually starting
to close in on Bernie Sanders at the
national level so let's look at a few
different things here our video audience
watching on our TV affiliates or free
speech TV or on YouTube
will see the polling data represented
visually on screen you will see that the
the trajectory of Joe Biden's polling
started with wit with Biden
pre-announcement polling in the mid to
high 20s and then spiking to more than
40 percent average in national polls
after he formally announced that yes
he's running for president
but then it started to not look so good
Joe Biden trailing off from like that
forty one forty two percent mark down to
about thirty eight percent which I told
you about at the time he continued
trailing off to around thirty five and a
half or thirty six he started this week
down even further around 33 or 34 in the
polls and Joe Biden has had another
really bad five days and he's now down
to 32 on average including a low of 27
percent in one a particular recent poll
from The Economist and YouGov now
earlier on you'll notice it was Bernie
Sanders who was benefiting from Biden's
drop in other words about six weeks ago
Bernie's gains were matching Joe Biden's
drop very closely with a little bit of
the Biden drop going elsewhere but in
the last ten days or so Biden has
continued to drop but Bernie has stayed
pretty even and it's actually been
Elizabeth Warren benefiting from the
loss of Joe Biden and slightly Pete
Budaj edge who has been climbing as Joe
Biden continues to falter this has been
a very solid week for Elizabeth Warren
she's now more solidly into the double
digits averaging about
eleven percent in the national polls and
as I said a month ago Elizabeth Warren
had been picking up on average one to
one-and-a-half percentage points per
month if she continues this into the
debates she could and the key word is
could could be in a position to actually
overtake Bernie Sanders and later on in
the program today I'm going to address
an audience question which wants to know
whether Bernie and Warren are
potentially going to sort of just split
the progressive vote and maybe hurt the
progressive movement in the long term
I'll talk about that later on in the
program the question for Elizabeth
Warren as the debates start will be is
she going to be better prepared for
these debates than she has in Prior
circumstances and maybe preparations not
the right word she's just not a great
debater right I love Elizabeth Warren's
policy focused town halls
I love the detailed campaign policy
proposals that she has released
I love the campaign she's running but I
recognize that on a debate stage with I
don't know how they're if it's going to
be nine candidates on each of the two
they're splitting the first two debates
into two groups because there are so
many Democratic candidates I don't know
if Elizabeth Warren on a stage with
eight other people is going to do well
in a way that is actually going to help
her polling because I just don't think
that's the best sort of setting for her
so this is national polling let's look
at a couple of other things including
Iowa because meanwhile in Iowa Joe Biden
is now barely leading at all Biden is
holding an average lead of just five
points in Iowa over Bernie Sanders with
a margin of error somewhere between
three and four typically that is not
particularly good for Joe Biden so I
believe that Iowa is effectively up for
grabs I don't mean Biden is losing as of
today what I mean is it's close enough
and far away and it's the the polling is
close enough and the caucus is far away
enough that the debates could actually
push Iowa to Bernie Sanders or even
potentially to somebody else depending
on how the debates go looking at New
Hampshire not surprisingly New Hampshire
has a different sort of
a theme New Hampshire Democrats are more
establishment centrist
than Iowa caucus-goers maybe and Joe
Biden has a larger lead there he's plus
13 in New Hampshire Iowa is the first
caucus the New Hampshire primary comes
after that so there are a couple of
different views on these polls and on
the 2020 primary one view is it's over
if you look at June of the year before
the election historically the leader in
June of the year before the election
usually ends up being the nominee
meaning its Biden and that's it that's
one view
ok the other view is this thing is
totally wide-open anyone can win this
and it's still early I think neither of
you is is probably the right one here it
is not wide open but there is still
certainly a chance for one of the other
frontrunners to win historically there
have been moments in June of the year
before the election where you have one
candidate polling 60% and then a bunch
of other people in the single digits
that is not the situation this year you
have Joe Biden dropping and only leading
Bernie Sanders by a much more modest
amount right now and you have multiple
candidates in double digits certainly
now Biden Sanders and Warren and that
could even change with Budaj edge or
maybe even Harris as the debates get
going so I do think that there is an
opportunity here for it to be somebody
other than Joe Biden I know that there
are some people emailing me who say
things like David nothing that has
happened in the past matters this time
around because everything is different
Trump as president as the status quo is
so different than anything that has
happened before the leftward swing of
Democratic voters is like nothing that
we've ever seen before
every election this happens every
election there's a contingent that says
nothing from the past matters because
this time it's so different I think that
these are new circumstances but anybody
who's polling under 1% is done ok I know
people are emailing me even saying that
people like Beto are about to surge
drastically as soon as the debates start
I don't think so and he's polling like 3
or 4 percent
but if you're pulling under 1% I mean
just it the dynamics are not so
different this year that you know I get
emails from people saying Tulsi is going
to so dominate the debates that she'll
be leading after the second debate
no she won't okay Beto is not all of a
sudden going to take the lead he should
go back to Texas and run against Senator
Cornyn there I think he's got a better
shot it is possible for someone from the
top three the top four maybe the top
five who could pull into the lead and
ultimately take this nomination
historically its most likely to be
Bernie or Biden okay given where the
polls are now given how these primaries
have gone basically every time in
history it's going to be Biden or Bernie
most likely and there is like a 99%
certainty that it will be Biden Sanders
Warren Budaj edge or Harris okay if
you're outside of that group I don't see
how you ultimately take this nomination
now that doesn't mean that you shouldn't
support someone outside of that group if
that's who you want to see when I
believe that a diverse primary is a good
thing I believe that you should support
whoever is most aligned with your values
and on the issues what I am telling you
in terms of a historical analysis is
that it is extraordinarily unlikely that
anyone outside of the current top five
ultimately is the nominee if you
disagree with me tell me either how am i
misunderstanding the current data or how
is the historical context not relevant
to what is going on this particular time
let me know I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
the show is on twitter at david pakman
show and it's a good one it's a good one
this week today's sponsor is Skillshare
and I'm excited to tell you that
everybody in our audience is getting two
entire months of free access to
Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video skill shares the
site that offers over 25,000 online
courses on almost any topic you can
imagine cooking meditation photography
video editing Photoshop managing a small
business almost an endless list and
whether you're trying to get ahead in
your career maybe you want to learn new
skills that will make
you better at your job you might just be
exploring a new hobby and you're trying
to find new ways to be creative in your
personal time skill shares the perfect
place to fully immerse yourself in
whatever you're trying to learn I really
enjoyed the class on more advanced video
editing techniques because it's
something I've been wanting to improve
at but have been very busy hosting the
david packard show for the last few
years
once again the david pakman show is
giving you two whole months of access to
every single class offered by Skillshare
after those two months if you want to
keep your subscription Skillshare super
affordable at less than ten bucks a
month get better at whatever it is that
you're passionate about or discover
something brand new that you didn't even
know that you would love and join skill
shares other 7 million users by clicking
the link underneath this video
[Music]